[Music]
we've been paying tribute all week to
some of the victims and survivors of one
October in tonight's story you'll meet
Tommy and Michelle a local couple whose
attempt to heal from the trauma took an
interesting turn of both growth and
gratitude
what days did you guys go in 2017 the
whole weekend we never missed a day for
locals Tommy and Michelle the Route 91
Harvest Festival was an annual stop to
celebrate their wedding anniversary in
2017 they were toasting four years of
marriage we'd stay for the weekend meet
up with friends and then Sunday that
year Aldine was there on Sunday that was
probably one of the honestly one of the
best Sundays of Route 91. until it
wasn't I knew instantly before Jason
Aldean was even rushed off the stage
that it sounded like shots fired they
dropped to the ground then stood then
ran if this is gonna happen something
bad's gonna happen I'm gonna die trying
to get home to my kids metro police
detectives have been Gathering and
reviewing massive amounts of evidence
this isn't a story about that tragic
night as much as it's about every day
since I'm very happy and fortunate that
I was given a second chance and I've
tried to make the most of it since I've
had it they felt the survivor's
obligation and they didn't just survived
they've thrived the past half decade
they've chosen to appreciate every
single day seek growth and truly live
fully in what is a path of a second
chance why am I here why do I keep like
getting out of these situations and for
me I always look at it like there God
has something planned for me on this
Earth and I need to make the best of it
psychologists call it post-traumatic
growth positive even transformative
change after trauma therapy and
counseling really does help especially
in those traumatic situations but they
also needed to take tangible steps to
give back first thanking the police who
saved so many that night Tommy a former
cop and Michelle went to the strip in
the days after one October to pass out
water and food to officers working
overtime thank them for everything they
did
um for me that you know law enforcement
means a lot I have a pass in law
enforcement so um doing that was able
like I was able to give back and it kind
of that helped me kind of move past it
one thing that was really great that we
did after the fact is that 5K for the
October one and so we were each given a
name of who we who we and I ran for
Hannah and I still remember that Fitness
provided a cathartic Outlet I never
really looked at it as a fitness thing
it was more of a for me it was more of a
mental thing we do an October 1 work out
every year on October 1 and it's
humbling it's hard for me it's emotional
it means a lot successful careers
flourished Michelle and surgical sales
Tommy is an elementary school teacher
but the most important aspect of life
since that night was having the
opportunity to continue to be mom and
dad to their two daughters you did this
by yourself good job I'm here and I'm
here with my family and I think about
the 58 families that lost a loved one
and then all the other hundreds of
people that were injured for me it just
became about the girls about our
daughters like just being there and
doing everything I could to make their
lives better
Michelle told me she now turns all her
have twos into get to's a change in
mentality that reflects the appreciation
that she and Tommy have for the past
five years and Beyond Denise